Spain Portugal and France have agreed to
build an underwater pipeline between
Marseille and Barcelona that would carry
natural gas and eventually hydrogen the
deal came after the three countries
decided to abandon plans to extend
extend the mid-cat gas pipeline that
would have led through the Pyrenees
meanwhile Germany is building pipelines
that are connect the four LNG terminals
under construction currently to the
National Grid projects like these would
have taken years to materialize in the
past but the Ukraine war and Germany's
energy needs have changed things
dramatically
where the Germans are going to freeze
this winter is being decided here at
this building site on Germany's North
Sea Coast manager Rani bandari is under
pressure and now the rain is holding
everything up
when it rains we have a problem the
ground is very wet here and it makes the
work much harder normally at this time
of the year there is no construction
work around here
to do that side
the pipeline is supposed to free Germany
of its dependence on Russian gas in just
a few weeks liquefied natural gas from
Qatar the USA and Norway should be
flowing here the work is going ahead
pretty much around the clock despite mud
and Rain the construction workers carry
on
we will be ready by winter December 20th
is the plan for commissioning the line
which can then guarantee the supply for
the winter
a few days after that the first LNG
tanker is due to arrive the special
ships can dock in the deep sea port a
mobile special pump ship will convert
the Deep Frozen LNG into gas and send it
through the new pipeline
environmentalists and a local citizens
initiative are usually opposed to this
kind of infrastructure project
objections and Court hearings often
delay construction for years
but this time it's different
because of the emergency situation we're
complaining less about the pipeline than
we would otherwise of course it's never
optimal when something like this is
built in nature
Rani bhandari is already thinking about
the time after the gas crisis in a few
years green hydrogen could flow through
these pipes instead of natural gas
all lines are hydrogen ready this means
that the entire pipeline is already
developed in such a way that it meets
the hydrogen standards
but first the manager and her team have
to ensure that the 1500 pipe sections
are put together in good time
Germany is counting on them
the energy crisis triggered by Russia
cutting gas supplies has created a rift
within the European Union at a summit in
Brussels EU leaders managed to agree on
a road map aimed at shielding consumers
from soaring prices but key differences
have not been settled most member States
including France are pushing for a cap
on what they're prepared to pay for gas
but Germany home to the eu's biggest
economy fears such a cap could see
suppliers seek alternative markets
earlier I asked UW correspondent Jack
parrick to tell us more about the road
map
right so the EU leaders have announced
what they're calling a road map it's a
bit of a bit of a bell here in Brussels
in other words similar to that is
framework essentially means they haven't
managed to come to an agreement so they
want to look at the way in which they
can come to an agreement on these issues
after 11 hours on this energy topic
lasting until about 4 a.m in the morning
they still couldn't get agreement on
this energy price cap so what they've
done is they've tasked the European
commission the executive arm of the
European Union to do basically a cost
and benefit analysis on that price cap
how much is it going to cost what can we
do with it essentially for the 15
countries including France as you
mentioned that are in favor of it to try
and persuade around the German
government that it would be worthwhile
that it is manageable that it will bring
consumer prices down and that it won't
skew the market so that there becomes a
lack of Supply whereas you say energy
producers decide to sell it in other
markets where they can get more money if
the European Union has capped the prices
they did manage to have some other
agreements like agreeing of voluntary
purchasing system for gas there's a
number of other issues surrounding
liquidity benchmarks on liquid natural
gas Imports Etc where they did manage to
get together but this big outstanding of
issue of the of the price cap that just
wasn't resolved and then we've had this
classic fudge as we say a road map to
get there
so Burning uh the midnight candle and
lots of coffee or tea I imagine what's
the likelihood the leading Powers
Germany and France will resolve their
differences on these measures
yeah it's really hard to tell at the
moment I suppose that cost and benefit
analysis will be pretty important we
know that EU energy ministers are
meeting at the beginning of next week
they will obviously have a little bit
more detail on these issues than the
than the leaders might have obviously
that being within their portfolio as you
say the franco-german access is really
the crucial one in the European Union
now especially after brexit it used to
be a sort of three three big powers of
the EU now it's only two which makes it
perhaps a little bit more difficult to
horse trade that was meant to be big
cabinet ministerial meetings between the
two countries next week but they were
postponed over these issues likely to
happen later on in the year if then it
really is now down to the to France and
Germany so knock heads and see if we can
get through hard to tell how quickly or
when that might happen
okay that's a DW correspondent Jack
Parrott many thanks